at the end of Jersey Shore there wasn't
like a grand ending it was just like
okay now it's over it didn't have an
ending I think it's cuz I got pregnant
so they were like all right she's
pregnant show is over so my son Lorenzo
he was in my belly he's 11 now and then
they wanted me to do sui and jayw which
is my spin-off that's when me and Jenny
got pregnant had kids on the show
whatever and then all the shows started
coming back like friends all the old
school shows and then we were like oh
maybe they'll want to bring us back and
then they brought us back and I'm like
we're on season 7 now of our new show
Jersey sh family vacation we just
started filming and Angelina's in the
mix yeah everybody gets along with her
now I mean she's drama I can tell you
that but like I don't want problems with
her and I think she's a good time she's
the drama of the show and she knows it